islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
a few people sent me this video of it's
a very very disturbing video
and subhanallah is called sleeping the
quran quran to sleep or quran
you can see it
uh
there on the screen now this is very
disturbing because they don't even leave
our quran alone now subhanallah like the
recitation that we listen to in our
houses you know to keep shayateen and
jinns away you know
etc which i'll let my daughter sleep to
etc it's not even free from these things
so panel and they're going to such
levels now we're going to decipher
somebody's deciphered what this person
is whispering obviously we can't play
for copyright reasons but you can if you
want to go and you know listen to i know
you guys might be curious um i i don't
think anything alarming the quran
is a shifa and it protects us from all
this kind of stuff so don't worry about
it let's not panic about it etc but it's
very disturbing that when you listen to
when i went i was like okay where is it
and i couldn't hear anything when i
listened closely there is a woman
actually speaking in the back
yeah there's a woman actually whispering
something i don't know what it was but
somebody actually deciphered it and this
is what he had to say
this is crazy guys our quran they don't
even know the quran alone these people
are involved in
they tell them to do these crazy things
just so they can have access and usually
sahara is used to break up marriages
yeah and that's what allah mentions in
the quran that when the angels came down
and said it told them to stay away from
it and people were using it
to what to break up marriages or in this
instance force this lady whoever she is
to get a man called owen brown back
because this is what it said there and i
will say at the mark four hours seven
minutes every 53 seconds she says the
following three times owen brown is
spending the rest of his life with me
repeats it four times while the quran is
playing in the background subtly yeah
owen brown is coming back to york
university for me owen brown listened to
every word i say to him owen brown
listened to every order i give him owen
brown listen to every word i say to him
this is some kind of a spell or
to get this individual owen brown back
in this woman's control okay it's very
very clear that this woman wants
control so god knows who told us to do
this but it's very very very bizarre
really not necessarily for for her to
pick surah baqarah the quran and whisper
this behind it this is very very scary
but obviously we shouldn't panic and get
paranoid the quran
itself and allah it protects us so let's
let's not get paranoid on on this matter
as well promises inshallah this is just
a video to just be very careful in this
specifically specific video and report
it i want you guys to report this video
inshallah which we're going to put um
which you can see on the screen
inshallah and you can see the comment
section people warning yeah okay there's
different places where you can listen to
uh quran recitation etc but be very very
careful because now they are attacking
the quran recitation subhanallah they're
not even leaving us to listen to our
quran the clam of allah subhanahu ta'ala
in peace probably says that's all i have
to say inshallah it's just an awareness
for everybody share this video far and
wide this is what's happening somebody's
deciphered it and this is what it had to
this is what it said so be very careful
when listening to these kind of stuff
and yeah and supanol even in one part
apparently in the beginning of the
this recitation she says at zero seconds
i understand and at 51 seconds she says
your cowards before
and then at one minute first thing i
said life is always mean meaningless two
minutes 22 seconds it says swallow yeah
so there's a lot of things that's going
on here but be very careful inshallah to
this specific video flag it and let's
get it taken down
and may allah protect us till next time
may allah bless you ramadan have a
ramadan full of barakah and happiness
inshallah um it's not worth going down
this route sadly you know it shows that
people are going
to levels just to get their loved ones
back to even commit shirk subhanallah
that's what i trust in allah have to
work on him and put our trust in him
inshallah until next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi